[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app it's
Chris D'Elia and here we are we're live
on my half let me go through some dates
here that I got coming up some cities
and some dates Durham North Carolina
there's a few tickets left Las Vegas
I'll be there on April 26 des Moines and
Sioux fall Sioux Falls May 2nd and 3rd
Fargo May 4th
Edmonton Alberta May 18th at Victoria BC
May 19th
Memphis Chattanooga and Knoxville that's
the 27th through the 29th Tarrytown New
Buffalo Michigan Chicago Illinois I got
all these coming up San Jose so that's
that's what I got coming up and we have
to make sure why are there two cameras
are we doing two angles now no okay
there's just two covers for no reason
there's one dummy cam so we hope you
enjoyed the April Fool's joke that we
did on your ass babies and whatever Theo
calls his guys Gang Gang we had a lot of
fun doing that [ __ ] and and we I who
knows if we'll do it again maybe we
won't but either way we hope you liked
it
we both got more [ __ ] we believe I
mean we should just switch each other's
podcast to be honest but because it's
like it just [ __ ] did so well broke
the internet as they say but it was
really fun and it was really cool to do
at whatever but you know I would
on the road in Albuquerque did I want to
start this [ __ ] show actually by
doing this this is so funny man
okay there's there's a weird m'p or no
matter what I say about anything on
Twitter
somebody's offended it doesn't matter it
really sincerely doesn't matter we live
in a really sensitive time a lot of
people are pretending that their
feelings are hurt and a lot of people's
feelings are actually hurt however I
just I don't think about [ __ ] my Twitter
isn't really for comedy it's just for me
doing dumb [ __ ] like I don't give a [ __ ]
about it you know so I tweeted I was in
the Albuquerque Airport and the my
flight was delayed for about two hours
and it said and and it was just I was
looking around at just how weird
Albuquerque was Albuquerque is so
Albuquerque like there's so many [ __ ]
like the artwork is just so I don't even
know what to call it it's like every
other [ __ ] painting is of a
stick-figure like this you know and like
Tetris like pyramids I don't know where
they got that or what the [ __ ] it is you
know I figure it's very Mexico inspired
but I just tweeted bro
Albuquerque you know I've been to some
[ __ ] holes but holy God you make
Jacksonville look like paradise whatever
Jacksonville Albuquerque you got some
great people actually I had a great time
in Albuquerque doing my show but once I
left the show where am i people live
there for some reason and it's all good
now here's the thing dude if I'm in LA
fine somebody says they [ __ ] hate Los
Angeles I go like this oh cool if I'm
from New Jersey I'm from Montclair New
Jersey if somebody says hey I'm from our
guru Jersey sucks I go like this that's
it I don't get my feelings hurt because
I am NOT my place but if someone says
hey you suck sometimes I get my feelings
hurt but most of the time ago like this
huh
grow your skin alright so I tweeted this
and I even think about it cuz I was just
in the airport and I was just like Jesus
Christ this [ __ ] place you know
imagine living here it made the news
pissed pissed there's an ad [ __ ] this ad
never go here [ __ ] ads on it's always a
woman with this voice as amazing outside
clothes that get out of here this is
what it said on the I made a set it was
a segment dude this is the funniest
[ __ ] thing good afternoon
Albuquerque has been a punching bag for
a few celebrities as they've made their
way through town the latest a well-known
comedian who bashed the city after
playing at a city-owned treasure the
Kimo news 13's Rebecca Adkins is live
there first of all you call your [ __ ]
theater Kimo which is how you help
cancer so all of a sudden your place is
making me think of cancer okay were you
playing chemo okay cool
cancer let's do this show let's rock out
guys hey hey cancer oh cool let's rock
out here we go you guys ready we playing
the cancer dome oh oh oh now here's how
bad [ __ ] Albuquerque sucks I'm
playing the [ __ ] thing and it won't
it won't play even the website is like
done they probably took it down because
they heard I was [ __ ] around with it
god damn it [ __ ] what's going on
here dude why won't it play
video will resume in 15 seconds it says
the [ __ ] play why won't this play oh
god damn dude you know what this goes
back to my [ __ ] if you're gonna invent
something make it work oh it's not
playing
I did i refreshed why won't this work
this how much our jerky sucks the
website won't even play all right I'm
gonna well here we go all right your
company keep your garage door and opener
functioning properly called the genuine
the original the overhead your company
today the overhead door company cool all
right
Albuquerque has been a punching bag for
a few celebrities as they've made their
way through town the latest a well-known
comedian who bashed the city after city
owned treasure the chemo the cancer
tells Rebecca Adkins is live there with
what is that any lady ly responding
Rebecca
there's a lady live at the place well
came according to ticket sales this is
where Chris D'Elia performed at last
Thursday but according to ticket sales
what just google it
exactly like they did so many [ __ ] so
much research
well according to stickit sales what do
you mean
cuz [ __ ] 1500 people bought tickets to
see me that's not according to his
ticket sales just look well according to
ticket sales and geographical location
of where the Kimo theater was and Krista
Leah's flight plan dude my computer's
broken yes yes my computer's broken dude
and you know you need one [ __ ] thing
for this [ __ ] dude and a goddamn
computer's broken man it didn't you know
what dude the day this [ __ ] sucks man
dude I just want one god digna you know
what dude I've been working so [ __ ]
hard man I've been going I've been
flying back and forth of [ __ ] cities
[ __ ] I said I mean I was an
Albuquerque dude I was in goddamn
Albuquerque I was in [ __ ] Albuquerque
you're crashed no [ __ ] my computer
crashed
what is it it just [ __ ] done dude
here one fire dude no flying solo [ __ ]
dude
thing to work dude I'm [ __ ] I went to
I went to I went to Albuquerque I went
to Santa Fe which is actually really
beautiful who knew dude it's so
beautiful it's like heaven you go to
Santa fast or to God and I went to I
went to uh you go to Albuquerque and
when I was talking to people to
Albuquerque they're like we go next I
was like Santa Fe and they were like ah
good luck you know what dude
do you know who you are Santa face
beautiful man if I die if I died and
woke up in Santa Fe and Jesus Christ was
like you gotta live here there for the
rest of your life I'm like this
smooth sailin dude there's hot springs
there's [ __ ] ten thousand ways
there's a place called ten thousand
waves where you can just go and chill
and hear water falling and and get
massages and it's a spa and you live
there dude you didn't live there I would
go there that's heaven dude my [ __ ]
computer's broken because I tried to
check a website about Albuquerque that's
how [ __ ] Albuquerque is it's a virus
and you know and and so I went and so
I'm so I'm there I'm in Albuquerque I'm
in Albuquerque I'm in Santa Fe New
Mexico I'm in Phoenix
by the way Phoenix I love Phoenix dude
every time you go to Phoenix dude I
swear to god Phoenix is the number one
place where groups of people wear the
same thing and hang out and walk around
together it's unbelievable you'll walk
around you'll see ladies with like blue
shirts on with like you know a shoulder
[ __ ] what do they call those things
that general have generals have for no
[ __ ] reasons you'll see like for
ladies with white pants and [ __ ] blue
shirts on with like those general what
do they call those [ __ ] epaulets yeah
having a [ __ ] epaulette the epileptic
seizure not even a joke you know just
try and just you do the joke so I
[ __ ] you'll see a guy you'll see a
bunch of guys with just like some red
Ohio State shirts on for no reason and
they're just walking around did I sort
of God I saw more people I saw more
groups of people wearing the same [ __ ]
then I saw anywhere else in in total in
my entire life in the one day I was in
Phoenix and I want one thing for the
[ __ ] thing [ __ ] for the thing to do I
wonder I want this to work
and I got to travel all around the world
I have one day in LA I come I'll and
shoot for [ __ ] you because I'm gonna
do season 2 I'm shooting all day
yesterday ok and then I come here I got
to do my pockets I got one day in LA to
do all my errands and I got to do my
podcast and the computer doesn't work
that's all I ask
that's all I ask dude I got to get my
[ __ ] car towed yesterday it's been in
my driveway for three days I mean three
weeks because I haven't had chance to
call [ __ ] triple-a across the ballet
to get my car they [ __ ] hook it up to
the [ __ ] tow truck guess what
happened dude no [ __ ] they crashed
it they scraped it the bumper is broken
it's a chip it looks like a [ __ ] chip
tooth it was something like some kid you
know in like fourth grade name cord ear
and I had a buddy and when I was in
elementary school his name was quad ear
and he was in second grade he had a chip
tooth and dude his name was quad deer
and he and and I said and he was so good
at talking [ __ ] to people he was so good
at making fun of people and I was like
hey quad do this guy's making fun of me
what should I do I need to make fun of
him what should I call him and he was
like oh [ __ ] man I was like well you're
really good at it he was like just call
him a big bunch
whoever's made he said whoever's making
fun you I will never forget this he said
whoever's making funny you just called
him a big group of Duncan [ __ ] monkeys
what's a conchita monkey is it a real
thing just call him a group of conchita
monkeys he said man just call him a
group of conchita monkeys I was like
conchita monkeys he was like yeah I said
okay and then I [ __ ] the guy was
talking [ __ ] to me I was like hey man
you know what you're just a conchita
monkey anyway I want the one [ __ ]
thing so they crashed my car and then
the lady called me up and she was like
hi do you want us to fix your car before
week cuz the reason why I call triple-a
is because the tire is flat and they
were like you and I'm not oh oh oh oh
and guess what do it I'm not changing it
I don't have a spare
anyway so that's out the door anyway but
she was she was like oh do you wants to
fix your bumper before we take it in to
where we bring it to two Audi to have
them do the tire and I was like fix it
but what he talking about it's like a
little scratch I was like nah nah
because I just figured was mine she's
like okay well cuz we did this and that
to it and and then it ended up scratch
like hold on you did it which is again I
was like okay well I want yeah well then
I need you to fix it are you kidding me
what happened and she was like she sent
me a picture of it bro it's it's it's
got a [ __ ] straight up what's not in
my bank account
dad it's got a [ __ ] dad write it in
the it's like big and so I I saw I was
like yeah you gotta fix that and they
were like okay we'll fix I was like no
you bring it to an Audi approved body
shop they're like oh no we could do it I
said no no that's not how it goes so
they're like okay let me get in touch
with my supervisor hey man supervise it
all the [ __ ] up man I don't give a [ __ ]
anyway dude these problems seem so
nothing but my point is I want my
goddamn computer to work so here is why
afternoon Albuquerque has been a
punching bag for a few countries they've
made their way through town the latest a
well-known comedian I was on stage when
I was on stage talking about Albuquerque
I said you know what Albuquerque is like
it's like a place oh no I said this in
Santa Fe the day after I said you know
what Albuquerque is like it's like a
plate it's like if the whole world blew
up and then they were like okay well I
guess we got to start from scratch and
then nine years later this is what they
had they're like we was kind of
impressive we did this at nine years but
also it's not as good as it was that's
why Albuquerque's like a
post-apocalyptic nine year nine years
after the post apocalypse
that's what Albuquerque's like and
they're like yeah we only got the
buildings this high but we have a
[ __ ] theater that we called chemo by
mistake and it's right
the [ __ ] cancer Mart hey we have the
[ __ ] tumor Valley [ __ ] what he
call the tumor Valley can I swear to god
dude I can't remember words and [ __ ]
what is the [ __ ] house that moves
mobile home um dude I'm so [ __ ] so
this is what I saw then I said on on
Twitter I was making fun Albuquerque
because if you live in Albuquerque you
got to know where the [ __ ] you live
don't pretend this [ __ ] isn't Narnia the
buildings go this high you got to crouch
down to get into any place ash the city
after playing at a city-owned treasure
the Kimo news 13's Rebecca actually
realized for sure what he said and how
people are responding Rebecca Rebecca
always with the way to las newscasters
dude when there jump on the last
sentence if you're in the field jump on
that last sentence jump on it we're
going live took this is me we're this is
me if I'm a newscaster we're going live
to Chris D'Elia in the field to see what
some of the locals have to say about hey
guys how's it going I'm cutting them off
I'm feeling it out dude rather than
that's way better than we're going live
to the field Chris D'Elia to see how
locals feel about what he said on
Twitter
hi how's it going I just wanted to do
this too long man
I could eat lunch in the middle of that
pause that plaus is so [ __ ] long a
baby came out of it so so still Lia
performed at last Thursday but while he
was here he had some sort of a bad
experience no your oh you're bad news I
didn't say I had a bad experience I just
said Albuquerque by just calling me an
actor you know what I mean
but letting me know you know what dude
you say other people's lines dude he
performed at the Kimo theater
[Applause]
I don't like how you laughed at dad to
be honest his second time in Albuquerque
but something on this visit left a bad
taste in his mouth who writes this [ __ ]
you know it's amazing but something
about this visit left a bad taste in his
mouth by the way they've shown the
theater in this video fourteen times so
far get more footage so much of this yet
from the top dude this is such a news to
get the top of the viewer and then come
back at the Kimo theater but something
left a bad taste in this comedians mouth
he tweeted on Twitter that Albuquerque
wasn't good we've talked to some of the
locals to see what they have to say
always [ __ ] panning down dude just
show it you don't have more footage just
cuz you're moving the camera we can tell
dude guess what every time they do this
to they [ __ ] come down and there's a
parts plus auto parts [ __ ] car
drive-by same footage also parts plus
auto parts if parts is in your [ __ ]
title twice change it parts plus auto
parts come on down to parts plus auto
parts where will parts if your parts and
parts that'll be parts fifty please
parts plus auto parts dude too many peas
[Laughter]
parts plus auto parts plus parts partum
depression parts pardon poor plots
pissing to piss parts parts dude
get it together Albuquerque you have a
[ __ ] auto place called parts plus
auto parts and also a theater and named
after cancer dude even Death Valley is
like we wouldn't have done that what
even Regina Saskatchewan is like wow
they [ __ ] up with their titles and we
rhyme with vagina
dude Regina are you kidding me
that's like naming your city pox cup
pock suckers hey guys were you from pock
suckers wait what like did you say
[ __ ] no I said pock suckers
that's a place because Regina is a place
I got to start over the [ __ ] goddamn
thing and now that it's not working
great because I because I waited too
long because the because Albuquerque is
obviously in some sort of deficit that
now I have to watch out another [ __ ]
ad for the overhead door it's it's it's
it's [ __ ] it's the overhead door is
what this [ __ ] company is called dude
Japanese degas look at these places look
at this places in Albuquerque exotic
flavors Oh fresh choices fresh choices
okay it's too funny anyways they've made
their way through town the latest a
well-known comedian who bashed the city
after playing at a city owned treasure
the Kimo News 13s Rebecca Adkins is live
there with what he said they're all
wearing what you'd think they're wearing
by the back
while came accordion Rebecca this is
where chris d'elia performed at last
thursday but while he was here he had
some sort of a fat experience and
Thursday night he performed at the Kimo
theater it was his second time in
Albuquerque but something on this visit
left a bad taste in his mouth a party
performance downtown he took to Twitter
to take a jab at Albuquerque saying I've
been to some blank holes but chuckles
God you make Jacksonville look like
paradise good deliver has been retweeted
almost 600
like I mean imagine it for that toy I
wish she said bro Albuquerque you know I
wish she said that part you make
jack-shit good afternoon
dude play scene I've been to some blank
holes but holy God you make Jacksonville
look like paradise the post has been
retweeted almost 6:00 God you know what
man I wish I said something besides
paradise just so they had to before I
put the tweet out I was like what's
better than para what's a funnier thing
the paradise but I was like ah who gives
a [ __ ] paradise is what everybody knows
I wish I wish I was more creative now
that they [ __ ] said it it would have
been so much better you know what I mean
Albuquerque ed oh he took to Twitter and
said I've been to some blank holes but
holy God you make Jacksonville look like
the inside of a sloshy [ __ ] you make
Jacksonville look like it makes the
sound slosh when it walks times I just
thought that was pretty rude of him it
was kind of unnecessary to bash a place
that you're attending you weren't too
happy doing why did they ask necessary -
thanks I just thought that was pretty
rude of him it was kind of unnecessary
to
a place that you're attending people we
spoke to weren't too happy about what he
said they don't give a [ __ ] people we
talked to weren't so happy not bad that
bad he's gotta go to good parts of it
you know what the good parts of
Albuquerque are Los Angeles but her
people had mixed feelings
this person listed off Albuquerque
staples like green chile and the
Sandia's and said what more could you
want others agreed with D'Elia with one
person saying they're from here and
should be offended but then said you're
right hashtag past the mess hashtag past
the meth head on fire shortly after that
tweet he posted again saying Albuquerque
and Jacksonville crowds are awesome
though actually but some people feel
posts like that could scare tourists
away they're probably not gonna want to
come here now he should probably
apologize for that
we also reached out to Albuquerque's
tourism department they say the post is
unfortunate but they'd like to know if
something's set daliyah off while he was
here they do say however they're
appreciative of all the locals that
stood up for the city came back to you
okay thanks for Becca now we also
reached to out to Daliya through his
Twitter we have not yet heard back
he didn't some nice things to say about
Santa Fe in Twitter after performing at
the lensing I mean just so many just
keep going and [ __ ] we wonder what he
thinks about Seattle just like okay you
know also let's it's a cliffhanger how
they left it although he did have some
nice things to say about Santa Fe by the
way what she's saying that at the end in
the background the next news is I swear
to god the next segment it says child
shot how did I beat out that story one
of Albuquerque's own slain but I tweeted
it was a blank hole maybe Albuquerque
that's the problem start from there
rename your theater and then move on
good how on earth is that a thing when I
saw it I laughed wholeheartedly dude I
laughed so hard when I was like oh my
god dude people are literally sliding
into my DMS with these emojis [ __ ] you
bro
don't come back to New Mexico hey guess
what man I didn't say anything about New
Mexico I Love New Mexico Santa Fe
bitchin Albuquerque sucks also I will
come back
I love the crowds the crowds in
Albuquerque are [ __ ] awesome the
people in Albuquerque are awesome stop
naming your theaters after cancer that's
all also I don't even really give a [ __ ]
I'm sure it's a [ __ ] great place I
bet I was there for eight hours twice
I'm sure it's fine how could you get
upset about somebody saying something
like that I mean I'm not talk about the
people in the news obviously they know
that even the newscasters are like this
is what we're reporting on this is
between this and one of the [ __ ] kids
we got got shot well let's lead with the
let's lead with the more depressing
story anyway blue apron you know we love
blue apron and if you're a baby you've
tasted blue apron that's how it goes
because blue apron I have yet to have a
bad meal blue apron sends me stuff I
don't even know I'm gonna like it I put
it in my mouth and it's beautiful it
feels like the end of a movie it's so so
awesome you want to taste what it's like
in the in the end of a movie in your
mouth get blue apron cross the country
without leaving your kitchen with blue
aprons best of the you of the US recipe
series featuring eight tasty weeks of
recipes inspired by regional favorites
well they had just a bunch of
Albuquerque flavored stuff blue apron
helps me discover my inner chef I cook
it and I make it and I taste it and it
feels like the end of the movie in my
mouth and you learn new recipes and
techniques I love cooking okay with blue
apron blue apron has exposed me to
delicious recipes I wouldn't have
thought to try with blue apron the hard
part
so done for me cooking isn't a burden
anymore in fact it's actually fun to
learn especially if you're doing with
someone else a little bit of a loved one
and you're having a good time and then
it feels like the middle of a movie
because you're doing the montage style
life lifestyle and each meal you do that
with blue apron helps make cooking at
home sustainable and it makes it a
weekly routine it's good for me I get
home Monday Tuesday sometimes I do it on
Monday Tuesday and then I go out back
out on the road to start making
delicious brag worthy meals at home also
Instagram looking Instagram picture
looking meals without the hassle try
blue apron check out this week's menu
and get sixty dollars off when you visit
blue apron home slash Congrats that's
blue apron comb / Congrats blue apron a
better way to cook calm stress is a
worldwide epidemic I feel it all the
time but guess what well also we're
working longer hours were inundated with
the constant news cycle this is what
affects me and we're more connected than
ever before honestly those three things
are my biggest problems long hours of
work the news cycle depresses the crap
out of me and I can't get rid of my
phone stress is a part of life and it
can very easily affect our overall
well-being it does for me but calm we're
partnering with calm it's the number one
app to help you reduce your anxiety and
stress and help you live better more
than 40 million people around the world
are downloading it have downloaded
already if you go to calm calm /
Congrats you'll get 25 percent off a
calm premium subscription within which
includes guided meditations on issues
like anxiety stress and focus including
a brand new meditation each day and
there are also sleep stories which are
bedtime stories for adults designed to
help you relax head to the magical
lavender fields of southern France with
Stephen Fry or explore the moonlit
jungles of Africa with the owner Louis
they have soothing music and all that
right now Congrats listeners get 25% off
a comp premiums subscription at com.com
/ Congrats that CA LM calm / Congrats
get online get unlimited access of all
of coms content today at calm calm /
congrats get calm and stop stressing
just like me post mates as usual your
stomach and the rest of your life are at
war you need to eat but you can't stop
doing what you're doing to deal with it
and the only fast things that deliver
are not what you want I
post mates all the time almost daily
maybe even daily you can use it any city
it's the best post mates the app that
adds a delivery option to your favorite
restaurants imagine anything you want to
eat delivered you don't have to drive
park or even talk on the phone to order
just download the app and order 24 hours
a day 365 days a year post mates will
bring you what you want within the hour
you can even see where your food is and
track your driver post base is your new
long-term like it's like kind of like
calling up and like if you want to hang
out like with a chick flick they would
say booty call that's what they have on
the coffee but I don't want to say it's
a munchies booty call because that
sounds corny but still as very cool
that you can do that with food and also
if you're sexist you can do it with
chicks but you know how it goes
we're more into loving relationships
here at the congratulations podcast for
a limited time post mates is giving you
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app today and
use code Congrats
that's congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
save the hassle get the food you love
fast at post mates with code congrats
congratulations is also brought to you
by the cash app the best app to keep you
baby's darkness um all right dude how
about that Albuquerque thing man that's
unreal we just love it though you know I
don't know it's not like here's the
thing I'm moving the fan over to me
here's the thing dude I don't know about
oh and I moved it too far
and I'm pissed I'm upset yeah coke on
fire do it yeah did I try to do it to
take it upon myself you guys don't have
a thing about me that makes me do that
yes do I do I live by the saying do it
yourself if you want it done right yes
did it work out no they're all work out
in the end because he fixed everything
yes could have been shorter yes wasn't
no and that's fine
[ __ ] dude the soundboard is all [ __ ]
by the way it's all good everyone's good
everyone's everyone's fired I'm fired
we're done we're quit ok ok
quick what's up from that movie [ __ ]
that thing you do and you doing that
thing you do any rukns a thing you own
own FA me that was the movie where I
thought Tom Hanks was gonna fall off I'm
not saying the movies bad I just thought
after all of the movies that he'd to
Philadelphia started [ __ ] getting
[ __ ] he started winning the Oscar I
thought oh this is the movie where he
just crumbles and then starts to do [ __ ]
stuff yeah and we do that thing you do
how was that music ever popular like I
know obviously that's not a real song
but how was that style of music like
[Music]
like what how did that guy not get
[ __ ] crucified or how about what's
that one do the twist you know crazy uh
let's see what I have in my [ __ ] I
don't know I don't know I I just that
fan feels good I wish I had it on the
whole time I wouldn't be [ __ ]
sweating did you guys see what Kodak
black said with the thing so it sucks
that uh obviously it's horrible that
nipsey Russell dizzy hustle got uh
nipsey Russell
Nipsey Hussle got killed if see
Russell's a guy named it after comedian
an old comedian
Nipsey Hussle got killed
obviously that's horrible I hate that
[ __ ] man so many rappers are dying as it
was who's dying more rappers or
comedians do it
so weirdest [ __ ] ever so so that is
obviously terrible and then Kodak black
that like [ __ ] troglodyte was just
like talking about how he wants to like
holler at his at his widow
which is just like what kind of a piece
of [ __ ] are you for real you know how
how can you be that big of a piece of
[ __ ]
like straight-up you're a piece of [ __ ]
you're a humdinger piece of [ __ ] to just
be like I'm ojala huh I give her a year
he said and then and then it was just
like people just blew him up online
which is stupid
everyone's got to relax I did it too but
I did it you know because who cares what
I say although maybe the people do but I
don't know but anyway and then what's
his name tea I came up with this this is
what tea I said to Kodak black which I
which made me be like do I have it here
is it every time you go to every time
you go to look at a video it's always
the the comment on the video I find that
link see if we could just find the TI
thing or it's white on Instagram
somewhere right it wasn't on his
Instagram actually it was insta insta
gram TI oh I'm sure he took it down here
we go of course dude nevermind instar
hey kodak that
you got a packet Niki fix this sheet you
add a pocket what does that even mean by
the way doesn't that mean you have to
pay something on your own I came out of
pocket I paid for it don't worry the
company I don't even need to be
reimbursed out of line okay that's
something for sure that gangsters just
had no idea what it meant and then they
just used it wrong and then it became a
thing Kotick by the way what's the girl
in the background talking about put your
feet in I love how t I was just like it
didn't tell anyone to be quiet like if
every time I do it I'm like everyone
shut the [ __ ] up I'm gonna do something
he's just like at the pool in like some
apartment complex and he presses play
and some girls I put your feet into her
kid
hey codec bet you got a packet Nick fix
this sheet
quickly expeditiously ah expeditiously
you know pack is Nikki okay again hey
nobody was gonna say you think I don't
see you digging if I see you I'm seeing
your face you have a packet maybe that's
it that's it then it cut off okay so Ti
is 50 it's so 50 years old to not know
when your Instagram video end and Frank
Howell does it all the time
Brian will be like hey guys I'm coming
to Minnesota tickets are still left
because you know that's what's up I just
wanted you to know to come grab tickets
too much and it'll end and then Totec
black goes like this
putting on his pants like through that
first this guy's looks all blue blue
pants blue shirt and eyeing his belt
like he's a [ __ ] like you in karate
with the Smurfs
when you're ready screen anymore that
was it that was his hot response there's
actually a better response there has to
be a better response I should I give you
send you that link so you know that link
let me [ __ ] find it but that was that
was that was the there's a better thing
Kodak black hey oh my god codec but but
dude I had a meeting with packet NIC di
one each this she quit and expeditiously
and he had three phones bro I had a
meeting with ti once he had three phones
limitary some dude nothing's more
disrespectful to everyone you would ever
cross paths with than having three
phones on you three not two he's like
your [ __ ] doctors [ __ ] [ __ ]
doctors I ain't got two phones [ __ ]
businessmen with them BlackBerry's and
iPhones I got three phones [ __ ]
I'm a businessman and a doctor uh
Instagram about TI I just so and by the
way how do you come how do you follow a
TI video and and make TI seem like he's
speaking Shakespeare TR that yacht
pocket it's prodigiously and then cut a
bag exact I mean [ __ ] code up black
looks like that remember that movie
critters
[ __ ] movie so anyway whatever uh
wow you know what Kota bite was like a
Simpson that's what he looks like that's
crazy dude he looks Li Simpson Wow even
his hair is like triangles a Simpson
correct Simpson but yeah he said it was
you see Instagram what he said on it's
so [ __ ] up these oh and then the game
said something - here we go cut it black
could it bleh you had a pocket you had a
pocket
oh he took it down cut a block is that I
don't give a [ __ ] he basically said I'll
give a [ __ ] I say what the forgot a
minute
I said what the [ __ ] a minute they want
to take it two things they want to talk
about the things that's it and I said it
a minute Oh anyway I gotta go back to
shooting the simpsons sniper gang you
know loyalty it says on his [ __ ]
biography loyalty out values everything
yeah okay anyway do it it's like the
game said it to though let me find the
game won the game the game the game
Instagram Kodak black black here we go
I'm just gonna [ __ ] play this play
here we go okay that's their response to
TI
[Music]
right now he said people trying to
misconstrue what I said literally said
exactly what he meant and people are
upset about that people trying to people
trying to say is disrespectful that I
said I'm a [ __ ] this rapper who died his
wife when I said I'm a [ __ ] this rapper
who dies wife then the game a Kodak
black and any other [ __ ] disrespecting
my [ __ ] nickname his legacy his family
[ __ ] keep my [ __ ] name out your
[ __ ] mouth [ __ ] keep his girl's name
on your [ __ ] mouth [ __ ] the [ __ ]
wrong with you new [ __ ] no respect
having ass [ __ ] man this new
generation y'all [ __ ] up in the head
[ __ ] stop disrespecting my nigga's name
man this [ __ ] for real my [ __ ] die down
hand these [ __ ] streets [ __ ] thought
of doing the right [ __ ] thing
doing good for [ __ ] people
first thing [ __ ] want to do after his
untimely demise
is disrespect his [ __ ] name naw [ __ ]
I ain't going for that keep my nigga's
name much of sir this is the last time I
take over pull your weight right here go
back black and then tank that's not it
bro that's not it I promise you that's
not it
listen to the guy I promise you hey man
I promise you that's not it you're the
Santa Sun another guy that's you know
trying to keep you from saying it period
got it
you got to get out of that you got a
you know there are a lot of factors at
play here you know I'm saying I'm not
only just the people that love and
respect knit and Lauren you know your
your you do business what else wet
Atlantic Records
ah that's a tough spot to be in young
fellas so let me just let you know right
now just get out in front of that man
and if you made no disrespect if you
meant no harm you know it's easier to
say that than the Plata you know played
a tough guy I don't fix this problem
okay that guy's so R&B from the [ __ ]
bones up dude the man that [ __ ] sounds
like the beginning of an R&B song
look man I'm down on bended knee right
now and I just want to say man get out
in front of that before your heart goes
cold and you know there's people out
there that would do you wrong and you in
a tough spot but you know where's the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] so that's a big yo
dawg okay so you secured the back in
good boys - man bro no they were so the
king of [ __ ] doing one note in to the
other note with no bending and they just
never just [ __ ] know
[Music]
so dude [ __ ] boys two men were like
you know what boy cement wasn't let's
make an R&B group [ __ ] whoever was
involved said well I know one thing
[ __ ] leaves every next for life did he
[ __ ] killed it with no sleeves this
is a hundred and twenty-two million
views ah dude wow that's amazing man
anyway codec black that's so [ __ ]
that's so disrespectful and also we know
it and also stop being a tough guy cuz
you would get your [ __ ] ass handed to
you by these [ __ ] other guys the game
you know I want to know who's whose I
saw this I keep seeing this thing I
don't know if it's in like the [ __ ]
lexicon or whatever like there's a
there's a thing you can do but you can
get like a premium snapchat which is
like a girl on a girl on on Instagram
will be like sign up for my premium
snapchat and you can get videos and
shows and
and it's the chick just showing her
[ __ ] and ass and tits on snapchat and
you pay for it let me ask you a question
who the [ __ ] in the world would pay to
see naked girls online or on your phone
when you simply don't have to hey would
you like to see someone naked sure would
you like to do it for free or would you
like to pay for it well I'd like to do
it for free that's what everybody would
say in the world what kind of chump ass
[ __ ] would watch would pay to
watch a girl also the fact that these
girls call it a show is so [ __ ]
ridiculous like that's a show and also
the producers is a show you can go to
[ __ ] Broadway and watch dr. Jekyll
and mr. Hyde or you can watch a girl
turn around
ah those aren't both shows one is the
other one is hookin the other one is a
disgrace the other one didn't have good
parents whatever dude you know and
people will be like you're slut-shaming
dude get I'd get so mad at [ __ ]
making fun of [ __ ] dude it doesn't
matter no matter what the [ __ ] I say
someone's gonna be pissed off so there
you go those are off babies yeah but
it's empower it's empowerment to show
your [ __ ] no it's not it's easy as
[ __ ] anything is it you know what I'm
scared I was not even the other [ __ ] to
it's like I was scared to come forward
and tell people about my my [ __ ]
anxiety and this and that it's and then
people be like that's so brave it's not
brave anymore you're expected to do it
nobody gets more championed nowadays
than somebody saying you know what I'm
gonna go public with my problem that's
not brave anymore
you literally get coddled it's the
safest [ __ ] thing you can do from now
on
is
say hey this happened to me and now I
have anxiety about it and I'm and and
I'm and I'm gonna be a nun brave and I'm
gonna say that I have [ __ ] OCD it's
not brave anymore I think it was bill
bird that was like yeah the first person
that did it is brave I can't remember
but it's just so [ __ ] the world we
live in I saw a post the other day that
was like so I'm upset and I was scared
to come up forward but I'm doing it
anyway and everyone was just thousands
of thousands of comments just you're so
brave you know it's brave not doing that
and just being a nobody instead you know
what I mean it's a truth not telling
people your problems and having nothing
to identify with that's not that's brave
nowadays being a simple just [ __ ]
person that goes unnoticed without a
profile on Instagram or anything like
that with no YouTube hits that's brave
to just be a person in the [ __ ] world
going at Target going to [ __ ] eat
sandwiches and nobody knows dick about
it that's the most brave [ __ ] you know
oh you woke up crying tell someone about
it not brave don't tell someone about it
you're brave as [ __ ]
keep crying deal with it yourself that's
what's brave oh dude it all went [ __ ]
back full circle you know people started
it was brave in the [ __ ] 80s and [ __ ]
that was brave as [ __ ] to show your
feelings that was brave in the 60s that
[ __ ] was brave now
it's brave to just suck it up and not
tell a person about it and have it
become cancer and then perform it at the
[ __ ] chemo theater in Albuquerque
Albuquerque
we're gonna do an elder we don't
normally do it at we don't normally do
elders we do them every now and then
because we can't just keep giving out
alder because by the way somebody came
up to me when one of my shows recently
and they were like wearing their elder
pin and I
just thought it was so [ __ ] cute man
it was so sweet and so nice that it made
me feel good that the guy was wearing it
for the show and he was like man you
really I love listening to you and this
and that now I was that that [ __ ] just
made me feel so good so we got an elder
this guy wrote me a message on on an
email when fire sent it to me and it the
the I'm not gonna read the good parts
about me like he gives me a lot of
compliments I don't want to [ __ ] make
this about me and that was very sweet
and thank you very much for doing that I
really appreciate you saying that
but anyway he says stuff I'm tough like
this in the in the in the in the message
I'm a [ __ ] baby through and through
man I've seen every single podcast you
make it easy for me and my friends to
relate to I know you're busy and you
can't reply to [ __ ] because you're busy
backing up that Brinks truck bro I'm
just trying to help you do it I keep
buying me undies I keep the cash app I
use your congrats code I just hope you
could see this man and I hope it somehow
makes your day even an inch better you
get me through my day at 9:00 to 5:00
9:00 to 5:00 I just hope you feel the
love that I have for you and you like
what you do for so many people please
please don't ever stop man you're so
awesome and when I see you tired when I
see you sick you're still on that
podcast you're sick and tired but you
still do it and I know it really isn't
for me but that's what it feels like you
know what dude then it goes on and on
and he's just talking about me so I'm
gonna need to read that but his name's
chase Robinson and this kind of thing
man this is why I'm gonna make you an
elder because you reading this kind of
[ __ ] makes me happy and it makes me do
the podcast it makes me charge to do the
podcast it helps me do the podcast and
it keeps my spirits up man like it's a
very cyclical thing man like I you know
you're telling me that it makes you feel
good that I do this podcast
well this parkus is for you man I think
what you meant says is not just for you
because it's for a lot of these babies
out there but this is for you it's for
me and it's for you and it's for all the
babies out there and you know I make
jokes about how I do it for money and I
get [ __ ] bags and all I do and I'd
you know obviously I'm gonna live that
hedonistic lifestyle and I want to
[ __ ] you know we love stuck in the
[ __ ] butt dude this [ __ ] is like the
real [ __ ] and chase
Benson thank you for relaying you're
very sweet message and you've listened
to every episode you keep those me on DS
on and you [ __ ] got the cash app and
all that [ __ ] and dude I just I can't
thank you enough for sending me such a
sweet message that wasn't backhanded for
some reason everything is always
backhanded but you just kept it real
dude and thank you very much and you're
an elder now dude because this made my
[ __ ] day and yeah you're right I'm
sick and I am tired and I still do do
the podcast and I do that because I know
that I have a fan base out there that
wants to listen to it and and now I know
you're out there and you want to listen
to it so I think about the fan base and
I think about you guys also think about
my pocket sometimes because I want to
[ __ ] keep the pretty short role in
Reverse there's a lot of different
things that make me want to do this
podcast but you're one of them dude so
thank you very much and now you got that
pin coming to you dude so we'll be in
touch with you and send you it send send
it out there yeah man that message made
my day
I got a foreword from a producer and you
were just like he was like maybe make
this kind of elder in Oz I dude you said
it anyway sign up for my premium
snapchat dude I'll show you my [ __ ] I'll
do a show where I just [ __ ] whip it
around like a helicopter can you guys do
that by the way I can do that I can do a
real finesse subtle move I do a [ __ ]
finesse subtle move it's a real subtle
you have to be really in control your
body you know who can't do it any of my
friends probably they don't have [ __ ]
can the connected tissue and the mind
can you do this bro can you do this boom
boom boom boom boom boom it's hard to do
it make your mind do what you do it's
hard to do it one fire just goes no
there's this guy called stretchy guy on
Instagram and he's like just always
stretching the guy looks like a guy
who's just gonna [ __ ] die tomorrow
and he's the stretchies guy in the world
and it's unbelievable and we got to
learn on [ __ ] doing all this [ __ ] I
guess I guess one goes down and then you
make those go it's very hard [ __ ] man
[ __ ] man it's hard to make your brain do
what your [ __ ] body want you to do
anyway my point is I could [ __ ] move
my dick around like a helicopter like
[ __ ] Petey Pablo I took that [ __ ] to the
next level this shirt I'll make my dick
swing around the kyla copter and Anaka
lamps over and [ __ ] like that I mean my
you know it's just insane do it I take
post frames get knocked sideways I mean
my car goes nuts dude what if a girl
when you took out your dick out for real
she went like this what the [ __ ] that
would make it any guy feel so good girls
do that [ __ ] to do it even if it's not
that big go whoa what the [ __ ] like
don't even do don't even go like wow
that's big
like really commit to it move back
open your mouth not for suckin but for
astonishment and then put your [ __ ]
hand about right above your titties and
go whoa what the [ __ ] the guy's gonna
get scared because it's not what usually
happens but then he says what go like
this that that's that is huge but go
like that make your [ __ ] eyebrows do
like this and make your chin go down and
go that is huge I think it goes really a
yes I don't even know how the [ __ ] you
have that in your pants and you walk
around all day what the [ __ ] do I need
to get you a sneaker to put on that
thing Jesus what's it like having to buy
two pairs of shoes because you need one
extra to tie on the end of your [ __ ]
Bell anyway dude
so okay you want to do misconnections
the tool misconnections i've got San
Francisco misconnections we've got San
Francisco misconnections here we go dude
about the hole I bet the the homosexual
ones are off the chain dude cuz that's
gay City right here we go you're need
help with your paint car Hey one thing's
for sure he's foreign or seven you're
need help with your paint car hi there
I'm a guy who can help with your car we
repair and paint contact to me what is
that is it a is it a [ __ ] thing this is
just regular your
I mean dude does this guy work for
[ __ ] parts Plus auto parts hi there
I'm a guy who can help with your car we
repair and paint contact to me dude do
not contact me well unsolicited services
or offers honesty is the first time I
ever believe that do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers Wow dude
what's up bro get it sexual men also
I'll [ __ ] you in your car that's amazing
this guy what the [ __ ] up with San
Francisco I thought this [ __ ] was gonna
be sexiest hell and the sexiest I'll get
out and this guy just is like I'll be
paying a car bro it's not even for money
he's just like I get off on it
Paulina at Costco this is for the very
sexy Paulina at the Ala meet at the
Alameda in Costco I wanted to talk to
more but my so was watching me like a
hawk thinking means son just put that in
on there but yet next time because you
have a booty to die for
ah so disrespectful immediately actually
kind of played it real nice and then got
this respectful on your ass literally I
would love for you to just sit on face
with that nice big booty what is up with
these [ __ ] man why don't they
put all the words in this goddamn things
it's unbelievable
this is for the this for the very sexy
Paulina at the Alameda and Costco I
wanted to talk to more about my show was
watching me like a hawk because you have
booty to die for
who wrote this Borat I would love for
you to just sit on face with that nice
big booty do not contact me move on
solicited services or offers bro that's
just wow the thought
leaving Costco and being like wow that
check man you know I'll just [ __ ] put
it on Craigslist maybe so it's just like
a crazy thought to me that's like a
wacky ass thought here we go looking for
Greg Greg I remember how you liked to
jack off while sucking my [ __ ] and after
I came you had almost always do a few
strokes more and shoot on to the towel
sitting between your legs
sure would enjoy getting back together
said descriptive at least this guy
[ __ ] tells us Greg if Greg reads that
Greg knows oh I'm that guy that was me I
remember when I give him those few extra
strokes and then jerk it off on the tote
in the towel in between my legs Greg I
remember how you liked to jack off while
sucking my [ __ ] and after I came you
would almost always do a few strokes
more and shoot onto the towel sitting
between your knees syrie non-sexual
sentence do not contact with unsolicited
services or offers looking for Greg a
movie with Hugh Grant for sure that
would come out in 1997 looking for Greg
about a man about a man who jacks of
jacks off another man and then goes the
extra few strokes along to put the town
between my leg and Jack off a little bit
in this summer jack off all over again
Hugh Grant in what is it go back Hugh
Grant in looking for Greg are you the
guy that used to let me jack off in your
car and then after I came you jack me
off a few extra strokes and then shot
and then I shot onto the town was
sitting in between your knees
this summer Hugh Grant will you jack me
off a few times after I come jack off
all over again when your best friend's
lover is your lover's best friend
this June bust a nut all over again
this June bust a nut all over a towel
and all over again in looking for Greg o
gold yes August
again alright next one
dollar tree coffee guy
okay so vague but not vague talked with
you about coffee today in line at dollar
store on sub Road thought you were
pretty cute maybe we can have some
coffee sometime lol do not contact me
this unsolicited offers you know what
this is actually kind of sweet that's
kind of sweet I hope this works out for
this guy that's cute I wonder if he's
talking about a guy or a girl you don't
even know should describe the girl you
know what if the girl was a guy who was
like oh I'm it was me but I don't know
it wasn't that specific it wasn't all
Hershey coffee on Sep Road and that's
just not sure man you know what pass and
then you will never ever [ __ ]
experienced
[Music]
I love what that guy comes in dude in
that video because we gonna celebrate
and he comes up behind me and put his
hand on your shoulder mm-hmm
wasn't part of the song and he wanted to
[ __ ] do it and the other guys so mad
it was like this is my point is my point
to shine and you [ __ ] put your hand
on my shoulder I went mm-hmm and you
made it about you when I don't even
really get those parts a lot you're
always poppin dude that would that's
some alpha [ __ ] wow that's so alpha dude
I'm gonna put that on my Instagram story
right now go to see it even though we'll
play it on the podcast tomorrow but this
is so alpha dude look how how look how
alpha this is look how alpha this is
what some put his hand on his shoulder
and did that
okay go to Instagram and look that is so
alpha anyway okay that you know I think
that's pretty much it yeah we're good
dude
remember we got the dates coming up dude
[Music]
Durham Raleigh area we're doing the
Durham Raleigh area we're doing that and
that's an April 12th coming up we got
Las Vegas Des Moines is it Des Moines or
Des Moines what is it des Moines Des
Moines Des Moines Des Moines Sioux Falls
when I say Des Moines but you want to
say Sioux fall even though it's Sioux
Falls Suites Falls Des Moines and Suites
Falls Fargo Edmonton Victoria British
Columbia British Columbia you know pick
one Hoover Alabama Memphis Tennessee
Memphis Chattanooga Knoxville Tarrytown
New York Atlantic City New Buffalo
Michigan Chicago Illinois Chicago
Illinois man I've got two big ones
coming up there at the Chicago theater
Chicago theater all right you guys what
do we got here
chase Robinson thanks for being the
elder download the cash app for free on
the App Store or Google Play market and
download the crystally app where you can
see the podcast before anybody else and
I subscribe to the YouTube channel
remember you can get gift cards at the
store crystalized or just click the link
and then also we got new merch we got
that do not contact me with unsolicited
services those prints are dope they got
them written all over the shirt and that
[ __ ] is kind of swaggy if you're filling
it tweet us and write and review that
[ __ ] on itunes it really helps you've
written really [ __ ] watch me on
comedians of the world man on fire and
I'm on that show you coming up and then
also I'm on the second season to you and
then also I'm on this new this new
series called huge in France with my
buddy GAD Elle Malaya I think that's a
pronounced last name name but he has a
new series coming out on Netflix this
week this week actually and I'm in a few
episodes of that where I play a version
of myself it's not myself but it's a
comedy it's pretty funny the show seemed
pretty funny when we were shooting it
I'm excited to see it so have a good one
guys thank you so much my babies and you
guys Rock okay catch you later
doc Simpson
[Music]